let's go to
gavin newsom page eight everybody if
you're listening to this it's like
you're a church go to page eight please
read your notes
go to psalms eight
line six right okay here we go
governor newsom has two potential
challengers for governor as recall
petition nears 1.5 million names
supporters have until march 17 2021 to
collect
1.495 709 signatures that's 1.495
million
709 signatures needed to trigger a
recall election
as of february 3rd organizer
announced that they had collected more
than 1.3 million signatures by the way
they've already collected over 1.3
million they only need 190 thousand
started in like november that's a scary
thought that's too quick california's
won the nineteenth i might have been a
little
like two or a day or two older i think
they're up to one point four i think
you're right mark
can you pull up to see how many
signatures they've gotten
uh for uh what do you call it recalled
newsome yeah
california is one of the 19 states that
allowed for allows for citizens to
recall elected officials according to
the california secretary of state
website the petition needs at least
1.495 million
or 12 percent of the 12 million votes uh
in the last
election for governor on monday
conservative commentator mike
cernovich announced that he would run
against newsome if a recall vote is
successful
in the state cernovich announced came
during a live stream video posted on his
twitter account where he said the
question is why i would run for governor
and the answer this answer is pretty
simple
in addition to cernovich billionaire
venture capitalist
shamath uh has suggested that he plans
to run against newsome
shamath has yet to publicly announce his
bid for governor
but he has been very critical of newsom
and has shown his support
for the recall petition is this well
deserved for newsome to be
uh recalled kicked out and not be the
governor of california what are your
thoughts
i mean we've been talking you're you're
born in
i'm sorry raised in california 24 years
you're your mom is from california i
know you're from norway
you i'm a florida boy so i'm not really
too up to speed on california politics
but
you know we've been since the basically
started the podcast since
everything that started with the
pandemic we've been covering what
gavin newsom has been doing and it
hasn't been pretty there we are you know
we
jokingly called him the u-haul
salesperson of the year everyone's
getting the hell out of california
and it seems like they are getting very
very very close
to this uh what is it recall for the
election
um my question is this just to kind of
give the other side of the coin because
it'd be very easy to bash new some you
you see on
you know even on snl they call them you
know you know
an inflatable sex doll he's just kind of
like this robotic
uh well he kind of reminds me of um
speaking of uh michael bury what was uh
what's uh who plays michael berry in the
movie christian bale christian bell's
character
in uh help me out here american psycho
with the j the hair gel it kind of has
that vibe going on
you tell me but my where i want to go is
this is
i can see that you can see that a little
bit right just kind of like this
soulless
sex doll kind of a guy mario you might
want to pull this up if you can
gavin newsome approval ratings in
california i'd love to see if we can
find
that data obviously he's a very
unlikable person he's getting a lot of
hate
i saw a person just basically mocking
him on youtube yesterday and it was
actually spot on
i want to know when this recal this
election would be and what his
current approval ratings are because you
might get 1.5
people to be a part of this recall um
but
if if he has high approval ratings in
the state of california
it might sort of be a moot point do we
have something here does that say 52
that's job approval job approval rating
that's what i'm looking for yeah
so his job approval rating is 52
that's not horrible bill de blasio's is
way lower than that in new york
so i mean if you're if you're using are
you a little shocked right now
if you had to guess where did you think
his job approval would be in the 30s
at least maybe the 40s 40s i mean trump
hovered somewhere between
40 and 45 38 and 45 his whole presidency
i don't think he ever cracked 50.
newsome we talked a lot of trash about
him yeah and i'll give it up to you now
but he's
still above 50 so i'm actually surprised
to see that's where he is so meaning
for all the pandemic stuff that he's
doing all the stuff the u-haul jokes
there's a large contingency that says no
he's pretty doing a pretty good job
here's here's a question for you here's
a question for you what is the most
liberal state in america
boom you got it cali maybe maybe boston
maybe massachusetts maybe hawaii
california california is probably the
most liberal state in america
okay think about san francisco think
about you know
lots areas in l.a think about santa
monica think about california's the most
liberal state
but not not way up north right i mean
that's when it gets a little bit more
conservative or even closer to the east
side of the state near nevada i agree
but it's it's probably your most
liberals the highest taxes in america
number one new york new york is i think
number eight
uh the best taxes in america is but so
if california was a country california
wouldn't be america
would be france california would be
a more liberal uh politically which
means
50 rating is is uh doesn't is
not surprising to me because it's like
yeah that's the country where most of
them want more social programs most of
them want more
of somebody on that side so yes of
course it would be a 50 you're not
surprised by that
zero that doesn't do anything for me
that doesn't do anything for me
all it does is is a simple thing look
right here
there's a guy last year right this
community right across it's called royal
palm
literally 200 yards from us right royal
palm okay one guy
his name is david i believe do you know
how much he sold in the last 12 months
in royal palm how much real estate
i showed it to you yeah you said he sold
like 700 no no no crazy
can you grab the brochure out of my
office it's the big blue brochure in my
office you can go to sam
grab the big blue brochure out of my app
it's going to be a nice advertisement
for him big blue brochure out of my
office
uh that has royal palm properties you'll
see it he was the guy in royal palm
737 million dollars of home sold
in one community wow in one community
so one year in one year in 12 months
okay in 12 months in one year almost
everybody you run into here when you
talk to them
how you doing are you how you doing you
know you so where are you from
jersey where are you from new york where
are you from why
why would i stay in new york i love new
york but why would i stay there new
york's only place i go to for vacation
okay here it is this is this is uh thank
you this is the
royal palm community i think i'm hoping
i said the number right
okay i don't know if i got the name yeah
you got it yep his name is david
okay how much did he sell 737 million
dollars from
january 1st to december 31st okay we're
talking about
in a two-year period he sold
737 million dollars why people are
leaving
they're leaving new york to come here
okay people are leaving california
you go to texas how many people were
your neighbors when you talked to where
you from california where are you from
california where are you from california
there are people that don't want to
leave california there are people that
just want to make sure california
improves there are people that are so
deep-rooted they're like listen man i
don't want to leave this place
i want to stay here i just don't want
this guy to be my governor
and i want policies to change there is
that community that's sick of it right
united the 1.4 million votes that he got
for the recall a third are moderate
democrats we talked about it last time
and it's getting very close if it's
getting to this point here that this is
going to be taking place
it wouldn't be a nice thing for him to
take place because of many of the
democrats when they're looking at their
lineup
of who could be the potential future
president he's on that list
he's on a list of a future president
just so you know oh absolutely he's on
the list
are you kidding me he's on a top five
he's on a short list
of somebody that could be he looks like
it he has a yeah california i just you
know he has got that
raspy voice he's a gruff voice but he's
he's he's a track you ever see him given
the answers the way he talks like he's
apologizing he knows the game he's been
in the game he looks the part he looks
the part but he talks he
the whole game he knows right he's a
politician he's a politician
i don't know if this is going to be a
good look for him if he ever runs for
office
i don't think this is going to be good
recall no way i don't think it's going
to be a good look for him if he gets the
record how many people do you know that
sign that recall
a lot really oh a lot how many people do
you know that says no that's my guy
i would never you you do a few okay i
actually because you got
roots in california thousands of people
there oh a few a few people that say no
i think it's okay i think we should let
him go he's not as bad as trump he's not
as bad as this he's not as bad as that
at least he's not cuomo where he let
you know he didn't give the right facts
about people being in the old folks home
or you know the
no and people died nursing homes at
least he didn't do it it's all about
at least at least so there is that
community they're giving him the benefit
a lot of people are sick of it do you
think there's an underground like the
the people that are voting to recall him
is it kind of the same underground that
started flocking behind trump in 2016
like the silent majority
look you know i got a call from one of
my
mentors advisors very successful
president of a multi-100 billion dollar
company
uh uh and he's in his 70s and we had a
great conversation to get he says look
in life
here's how it works he says you're gonna
have battles
there's gonna be little fights that
happens all the time with you and
somebody with you and family with you
and a friend with you and all that stuff
he says the goal is to try to get the
battles to be done somebody wins you
move on everybody goes about their
business right
he says then there's wars when there is
a war you have to know that every
country has to defend themselves
okay i have to defend me you have to
defend you and you know there's going to
be some
casualties at the end of the war no
matter what if you go to war there's
casualties
he said then there's nuclear wars when
it's nuclear wars
it lasts a long time and the amount of
blood in your hands is going to be a lot
last 12 months politically was a nuclear
war and
the way they went after trump it doesn't
end there it's not like there's no
residual effects to it there's
still going on right now it's nothing
it's nothing the residual effects of the
last 12 months is not a one-year
residual effect
the residual effects of the last 12
months is a 10 20 year residual effects
are you kidding me
let me put it to you this way the
residual effects of the last 12 months
could be 25-year
uh effects of a barren trump type of
residual effect
like you have to know you offended my
dad
so so this what they did last year may
be like hey
it's called you know oh yeah so you did
that to trump we're going to do this to
know some we're going to do this
so so they started it and said for today
they started a nuclear
war and it's not you took trump off
watch how long it takes until the next
damn president
just what are you going to say no so
they started a
nuclear war and now they're impeaching
who in the world
cares about a former president being
impeached like let me say this one word
like okay
it's like saying i'm gonna fire an old
employee that i've already let go of
what are you talking about so so you
understand like you came you served your
six months or twelve months
a year later i want to change it from
that you just did your time and your
contract you wrapped it up no no
i want to change it to i fired you
what are you talking about no one in the
world cares about a former president
being impeached move on
he's a former one-term president what's
worse than being a one-term president
how many one-term presidents do we have
been impeached twice you know what it is
to be a one-term prayer what's worse
than a one-term president
jimmy carter one term senior one term
there is nothing worse than being a
one-term president nothing for a
president are you saying they should not
even prove no
any illegals are already bad enough but
since they're doing it they just have to
be prepared
for the nuclear war in the world of
politics
are you saying that they should i'm not
i'm not saying that this is we're
this is conversation right here should
they not pursue what's
cause they just started this you know
second impeachment trial everything
that's going on should they or should
they not yeah it's not shitty or should
they not okay
a long time ago i had to you know in my
20s
it was always about no but they're wrong
no but they're wrong no but they're
wrong
look listen after plenty of books to
read and mentors
counsel all this stuff dude you don't
need to win everything
certain things you just just gotta let
go of it this is not worth it this is
embarrassing
why do you think they're going after
himself it's it's i think it's a little
too much i think it's like
proven a point he's the first to be
impeached twice do you think there's a
any part of it where they're trying to
make sure that he's
barred from from running i think that's
the big one trying to put the nail in
the coffin
100 that's it but i tell you one i
talked to oliver north
yesterday or two days ago yesterday i
and i said who's your number one
candidate for 2024
he said mike pence i said okay i said
do you think trump should run in 2024.
he said no absolutely not he says
they're going to destroy his businesses
they're going to go after him he says
what he needs to be focused on right now
is to take care of his family
because it's going to be pretty ugly
this is all of our notes you'll see i'm
prepping
obviously i'm uh you know yeah and by
the way i'm familiar with oliver north
yeah um iran contract yeah he talks
about it
he's a former general what was what was
lieutenant colonel
famous in the early 80s this when was
the iran contract 81 84 like that
he was famous for a big trial on capitol
hill
yep you know for those of you who are
not familiar got arrested for those you
know
five people were not arrested guilty
okay so he was one of them poindexter i
think was another one
uh of five cia agents and a couple other
names
this is like the equivalent i'm i'm not
exact but like this is a watergate-ish
benghazi type in the news
type of it was like holy moly oliver
north on trial yeah so it was a 30
million dollar
money that they got to work with i think
a country that they were protecting the
country you know nicaragua but it's a
small region of it
and they took out it at 13 again i you
can go verify this 18 million
to buy uh weapons for iran and give
weapons to so it was a very
uh interesting thing that took place
this is also on the tail end of the cold
war so you have the whole russia
or communism versus capitalism and and
the ideolo
ideological fight as well yeah yeah so
so the whole challenge is you know
oliver north said i don't think he needs
to run i think he needs to take care of
his family but
the point i'm trying to make here was
newsom i'm not surprised
you you caused a nuclear war so when you
cause a nuclear war there's going to be
a few what
casualties news is going to be one of
them period newsom is a casualty
because of the nuclear war and i think
they knew they're going to have
casualties
i think they knew they were going to
have casualties this if it happens
you potentially eliminated one of your
future presidents
and and he's a high draft pick by the
way very high traffic he's the top five
candidate
and the thing with you know as with
anything it's a lot of it has to do with
optics optics right so you know
again like we said polish good looking
you know kind of looks like uh christian
bale's character in american psycho hair
gel you know kind of
but when he's shutting down all the
wineries
himself and then he apparently owns a
winery and the one
his one freak you own a winery bro oh
his
one winery is open and he's yeah and
he's they're
drinking french laundry restaurant
parties
distancing getting very easy to be like
get this douche bag out of here it's
just very easy to feel that
i think that's the word though i think
that's a word to describe in
and look you you knew you knew folks
like that in high school
who liked guys like that you know behind
closers you're like dude just stop i saw
you're so annoying right
you get over yourself buddy you know
you're you're you're not as
you know uh amazing as you think you are
it's a bit annoying the way you are like
as a california if you if you're
watching this i'm actually curious right
now we have 178 thumbs up
233 thumbs up one thumb down okay
i'm curious if you're watching this
recall
thumbs up smash thumbs up if you say he
needs to get out
we need to recall and we need to move on
and get a shamath or somebody else
no he's doing a good job let's keep him
in there press thumbs down
i'm curious thumbs up out thumbs down
it's fine let's just keep him in there
continue you were saying as a
californian because you keep obviously a
closer tab on california politics
who do people in california dislike more
newsome or la mayor eric garcetti
it's it's not even a question on how it
is i mean newsom's on that list number
one because newsome's a governor it's
not it's an unfair
uh it's like saying who do people like
more a high school basketball player or
an nba player newsom is a nba player
newsom is playing on the big leagues one
of 50.
how many mayors you got in america of
course it's a bigger mayor you're mayor
of l.a
i get it but garcetti bloomberg you know
it's it's uh you know
no it's it's not even close no no no
okay i think the influence like
uh newsome probably influences garcetti
more than garcia influences
i agree yeah i agree and by the way
garcetti is a more yes sir person
bloomberg is not bloom not no uh de
blasio is not
de blasio fights yeah uh cuomo cuomo is
like dude what are you talking about let
the amazon people come and put their
jobs here no
it's not fair it's like what is what is
the matter with you right
so so and newsome are on the same page
de blasio and cuomo they're not on the
same page so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you